this is the story of Alejandro
father gave him everything but she had a
recurring dream of Alejandro leaving the
safe world she created where it faced
the dangers he tried so hard to keep him
from
Los Angeles
uh Alejandro Martinez yes Mr Khalil is
ready for you thank you
okay look if you don't have a while you
have a month to find someone to co-sign
your visa and if you don't you have to
leave the US I started freelancing for
this lady I'm late I know I'm late I'm
so late oh this menu what is it with
walnuts walnuts walnuts walnuts it's
like a cafe for squirrels walnuts they
go very nicely with the salad do I don't
like I need educating on fine cuisine
you think this lady can sponsor you
I I mean we'll see we'll see
is this your dream making toys yeah help
me curate an exhibitions
the other thing is you can't take money
right now you must find a sponsor and
pay fees to earn money the maze is
impossible to navigate wait I mean this
sucks so much for you
I'm barely keeping a flow your boss is a
monster I need to get paid
a nightmare none of those options
my question if you are ready for this
job why are you making everything so
difficult
[Music]
you don't know what it is to really want
something to be on a mission journeying
into the unknown
it sounds Brave
it's so simple Alejandro this is it
sky's the limit
[Music]
oh El Salvador
yes and those nuns they killed in the
80s right so